anything out of that game I know you scored five
it was gravy Carolina with a chance as teravan
keeps it in stuck chance out in front camper
makes the save rebound collected by fost he'll
dump it for Terra now it's worked across SL is
shot deflected just wide another chance out in
front I'd like to see Cami entered into that mix
Center IED position tonight now a chance out in
front and a big save made as it was oetkin
on ketov net for oetkin there as Carolina
will try to clear right off the draw first time
he's played against oetkin kochetov his first
ever start against Washington now Carlson he'll
keep this in turning with an opportunity and a
low shot put on by stro that save made by ketov
Carolina can't clear now out in front spinning
with it oh that's get another save kochetov
out about three on that shift now a chance for
Washington is coming in is brus delivered out and
Fred coach jov gets across with the stick somehow
finding a way to rob the Washington Capitals
a huge save stick or the post I mean Big Time
Puck luck well Puck luck is what you make of it
it's a goalie there's a guy that won a national
championship with Quinn Pak with Rod's son Skyler
has played very well in the east coast league and
you know I think he's here you know for NES for
burns back for NES 23 seconds left in the double
minor a burn shot deflected right on and keer
with a big pad save and the Caps will clear tip
of the hat to the Penalty killing from the cats
now slaven keeps this in he'll find Ken he finds
ter Nate just shot right on Save made by camper
leak through him just gets it his far as the Kan
blue line now coachi helps play it out and Bunning
coachi will flip one right on and keer will catch
and hang on with 642 left in the first period
watching them play quite a bit this year I like
the way that they play they they typically don't
beat themselves and they've gotten better goal
tending than last year the best one-time in NHL
history just 8 for 80 this year penalty Killers
good late 27 of their last 29 and they will do the
job here early flicking this all the way down the
ring slaven trying to clear he and Wilson fighting
for it again not about one guy but a wake up call
to the other guys in the room is now terrain and
AO and now slaven comes in his shot and keer makes
the save because he had a passing option okay so
he knows he's got AO as an option and he thinks
that keer might be thinking about it and opening
up to push from right to left that's why he goes
five Hall good thought from slave he looks over
he sees AO what you know what he got Washington
now AO he'll go rank wide try to settle it down
terine to putting but that's it LIF and now a
break coming in it's Wilson and Coach jov stares
him down he catches it and hangs on I I I hope
they start to get some more looks because the
first group is Ling I think and it leads to a
short-handed chance now Washington trying to go
to work in the Game Zone snively with it but he
has that interrupted there's n with it could
be numbers for Carolina s across jackfield
shoots save temper and then he sweeps across and
covers it up heck of a job picking off that pass
defensively from n then finds chadfield at top
speed gets it to his forehand which makes the
pass easier settles for Jaylen at the last second
great save from keer skating ability has been very
noticeable both ends of the ring as Carolina will
win the offensive draw n's hammers one and as jury
wins the draw get it to just now slaven buning
GPS a shot and AO he'll hook with it s De getting
tired mantha trying to find a way off with the
Kane's keeping it right back in with a chain shot
gets through net front by Martin xve keer in the
defensive Zone well the stall line has done what
they need to do it might take you to the third
period to get rewarded but that's how you're going
to take advantage of a team that played last night
it might take until then and that has to be the
approach now ke up foro he scores oh one timer and
a finish rocket delivered by AO it's one- nothing
Carolina to the shift that the stall line
had just completed fresh bodies firstman
pressure from Jarvis support along the goal
line from n that causes the turnover and the
high forward who is the centerman finds
a soft area and Jarvis for the second
consecutive second period puts it right in
the Wheelhouse for an a one timer and bang low
[Applause] change and now a long stretch pass
fores trying to send one out in front he does
but neatly tied up was bunny I don't think that
Nate just LED bunting with the pass as much as
he wanted to now a chance for Washington and
the score right down Broadway Martin farari the
defenseman jumps into the play and we're tied
at one so Carolina had that transition chance
to extend the lead hurricanes aren't able to cut
it off at their own Blue Line yeah NIS and burns
really run into each other and that's what created
the big breakdown farari is a good hockey player
surprising to me that he was sitting on zero
goals at this point in the season Bost slaven
doing heavy lifting along the boards washing Kon
with it that runs off the post they think they
scored referee wavs it up and up comes D'Angelo
as close as it yes from Anthony mantha Puck
goes off the bar off the post the Washington
bench thought it hit the back bar it clearly
didn't three minutes gone by here in the second
period Kane's now trying to work something in
the Washington Zone Cami with a WRA chance oh
a neat little play there by sberry Cod KMI but
keer I but Steph n coming back turning a puck
over Carolina's favor and then he's back on
the rush kenami uses the back of the net well
he couldn't get it to the net as quickly as he
wanted keer was a little tardy and farari farari
made strome sharp angle shot St Coop a little bit
now it takes a bounce out in front wi gets to it
now Strow with his shot right on and a save made
by coacho now Jarvis sends it across AO low
Drive save made by keer as tries to get to it
kept in by Shay and up for pesi clicks it off the
crossbar watch n i mean totally taking away the
goenda eclipsing
screen well that lead off and here comes Sebastian
AO he's one for one this year AO in on keer Waits
back in forehand and keer seals off the bottom
of the net I I'd like to see Sebastian come in
with more speed here or maybe a quick quick
little rotation of the wrist and go between
the legs here he comes at the snails pace now
just push it forward now he'll get to it he's
one for three on the year and he'll score
and he has some unpredictability makes you
uncomfortable too with his slow as he's coming
in there's nothing illegal about it here comes
Tavo Terra ven he comes in on keer forand and
keer gets a piece to make a save to keep this
going he gets going east west maybe not as much
as he wanted to he had long time defenseman for
the Caps now he's got speed in on coov and ketov
gets a piece to give Carolina a chance to extend
the shootout you know it just allowed coach
OV to be more inan his attempt this year was
an ofer see if he can get to 500 coming in
on keer and he misses the net and Washington
will get the extra point as they'll win
this game to two to one in the shootout